[Music]
I think the bass sounds like this, but I don't know
if it sounds exactly like your grandson's voice.
Yo
There's not enough space in the skull,
the bottom
line is that Hankyu needs Ogu Station
.
Ostriches have too many muscles to move their eyes, so they don't have enough space
to move their heads to see what they want to see
.
It's
kind of cute,
isn't it?  By the
way, there's one more thing,
isn't there 2 pieces of this expression of the mouth
?  I wonder if I'm walking away from the
answer.Eguchi-kun's opinion is correct.What
do you eat to live?If you have two eyes in front of you, you
're not a herbivore, but a carnivore.
I guess you can tell just by the position of your eyes, so it's easier to spot enemies if you're on your side because you have a wider field of vision
.
You can see three-dimensionally and you can see the distance to the prey
Ah, it's an animal that wants to catch
animals, isn't it?